un mar de telas negras frente a una
universidad de kabul este fin de semana
a la cual las redes sociales
respondieron con una ola de colores
rebeldes este tuit de la académica
afgana bajar yalal y desencadenó el
movimiento aparece con un vestido suelto
verde y rojo y con este breve comentario
llegó un vestido tradicional afgano esta
es la cultura afgana desde entonces el
hashtag ha sido ampliamente difundido
para cambiar la imagen de la mujer en
burka negro
no quiero que el mundo piense que esto
es lo que somos que esta es nuestra
cultura que de alguna manera esto
representa a afganistán conozco el poder
de los medios de comunicación el poder
que pueden tener las imágenes en todo el
mundo así que publique una foto mía con
la vestimenta tradicional afgana y pido
a las otras mujeres afganas de todo el
mundo que hagan lo mismo porque las
imágenes hablan y matthew turner
los talibanes anunciaron que las mujeres
podrán estudiar pero separadas de los
hombres y tendrán también que llevar un
velo completo
estas coloridas imágenes representan una
resistencia contra las estrictas normas
de los nuevos líderes del país
afganistán es de ley drivers con
afganistán es un país muy diverso con
más de 14 grupos étnicos y todos tenemos
nuestra propia vestimenta tradicional
station clouds y ninguna de ellas es lo
que los talibanes quieren imponernos
esta protesta en línea no se refiere
únicamente a la ropa de las mujeres la
cultura afgana es también arte poesía y
música tantas prácticas prohibidas total
o parcialmente por los talibanes